午前歯ブラシでちょっとありがとうございますはいどうも貴さんや
はい
ドアってすごいな
でもすごいですねドアすげえよな会津はそうです
ドアってしまうじゃん
しまいますどーんと行ってしまうんですよ閉まり原因としてまー
鍵がかかるとかなかったて夏横にするとかどうやってすごいんですよあれ
開くものなのに閉じることができるっていう常識があるようで実は女子気がない
今日母とオーナーなんです
なるほど次の人間の概念としてはドアの鍵がかかってなかったり録画されてなかったり
したらどうは絶対開くものだと思うんですよね鍵を解除した開くと思う際
ロック取ったら開くところですかはい
違うんだなぁ
というわけで今回は普通の人あの家の扉もカギ開けば余裕で開くんですけど今回はこの
アロンアルファーを使って完全に閉じてみようと思います
ああなるほどはい驚けでしょ喜納さんみんなは困難ですんで開き
明けてもうわからない誰かをしてるわけでもないなんでなんでなんで狙ってパニくると
思うんですよその人様が馬鹿みたいに抱卵するさんも今日は
食べて見届けていきたいとおもいますバカな顔してを売る馬鹿みてね吊らパニックなど
で
うーんあのさすがにあの賃貸の家の音はもう決着時つけるな
ちょっとさにヤバイと思ったので一応奴に確認したところ朗報やさんから共感いただけ
ます
早い
する早速いるドアを接着剤でくっつけていきましょうかもよああ
ね金属でメーターも金属だがいけると思うんですよ
行きなさい
[拍手]
ん
持っていています
ドンッ
ん
[音楽]
はいというえなってしまいました
check it
というわけで早速ターゲット4でしょうな奴やな
ちょっとそのしてもいいうーん
[音楽]
だ一度動きます
あんっ
うん
別れるん
ん
[音楽]
うん
なんだこれ
[音楽]
安けりゃ長期低 per ej
ええええええええええええ
を際でしょビガー
ran
ブーブー意識正氏
ウォッチ r 002本当にアンチじゃないんだろ
持っておけるは掘ってるんだけど page ぜひ真ん中
ええええ
の iaea
4日らぁぁ
[音楽]
me
teame
car
uh
うわぁ
はどういうこと